[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
football's coming home
[Applause]
gradually this is how it used to be
fans streaming along wembley way on
their way to an england international
in 2019 now three showpiece domestic
games at wembley
the semi-final and the final of the fa
cup and the carabao cup final
will be among nine vaccine passport
trials
with fans allowed back in the stadium in
april and may
the government says it's developing a
system for covid status certification
the idea is to manage risks where large
numbers of people
are in close proximity not in pubs or
restaurants at this stage
but at sports events and festivals or in
theaters and nightclubs
at this large nightclub in london before
lockdown
it could accommodate up to 1400
revellers
but the manager fears vaccine passports
could be another burden
on an industry already on the brink if
they're going to start cutting
capacities if they're going to start
letting less people in
or we're going to slow queues down from
coming into venues you know it's just
going to have an adverse effect
it's just going to you know they'll
delay the inevitable and
eventually venues will run out they'll
be strapped for cash they won't be able
to operate
because the the restrictions are just
going to be too too heavy on venues
the cabinet office minister michael gove
says the government is studying a green
pass system used in israel which allows
people who've been vaccinated
recently recovered from covid or have
had a negative test
to congregate in theaters and nightclubs
but the strong opposition to vaccine
passports from many mps
this weekend a cross-party group of
mps signed a pledge opposing the scheme
claiming it's divisive and
discriminatory
if the plan does require legislation the
government may try to win over the
rebels
by promising it'll only be temporary
perhaps for no more than a year
besides vaccine passports boris johnson
will tomorrow
also announce new plans for
international travel this summer
travellers will face a traffic light
system
people returning from a green light
country will not have to self-isolate
but will need to provide a negative test
before departure
and after arrival those returning from
an
amber country must self-isolate at home
while anyone returning from a red-light
country will have to complete quarantine
in a hotel
and bear the cost
summer holidays to europe will depend of
course
on vaccination levels on the continent
improving
and infection rates falling john craig
sky news